scenes like this were common in myanmar
until wednesday
crowds of people used to wait for hours
to get oxygen for a loved one
suffering from covet 19.
people are worried and scared there's
also been pressure from the military
telling people not to queue for oxygen
the junta has now imposed a new rule
people will need a letter from their
local administrator to obtain
oxygen like much of southeast asia
myanmar is experiencing its worst wave
of coronavirus infections
its healthcare system ravaged by decades
of military dictatorship
is struggling to cope the coup in
january
and the subsequent crackdown on medical
professionals for being one of the first
groups to go on strike is turning an
already dangerous health crisis
more deadly the military are closing
down charity clinics and arresting
doctors who volunteer there
they pretend to be patients and arrest
doctors that's why doctors are on the
run and in hiding
the junta has denied carrying out such
operations
this doctor who wants to keep his
identity secret
says he and his colleagues have had to
resort to using their phones to give
consultations
he estimates at least 70 percent of his
patients have tested positive for
coronavirus
hospitals are not accepting patients
i've heard of soldiers pointing their
guns at patients and telling them to go
home
they should not be the ones deciding who
gets admitted to hospital
some patients are also reluctant to go
to government health centers
citing a distrust of military-run
facilities
many end up self-isolating at home in
yangon
residents hang out yellow flags to show
they need medical supplies
hoping volunteers will help the number
of people
dying in their homes is increasing
ambulance services normally take
patients to hospitals but these days
there are more requests to pick up
bodies
funeral services are overloaded some
families have had to wait several days
before a body can be transported
as coronavirus infections and deaths
soar
the un independent expert on human
rights in myanmar tom andrews
has called for a covert ceasefire urging
the international community to pressure
the junta to stop its attacks on
healthcare workers
so they can do what they are meant to do
deliver medical care
florence louis al jazeera